the left-hander robbie ray one winning
six starts the era near eight and a half
but signs last week bob of some progress
with those mechanical changes so
back-to-back walks to begin
and that'll bring up nolan
and nolan hits it hard into left field
and it is going to get to the wall as it
gets by peralta
scoring hamson scoring trevor's story a
two-run double for nolan arenado the
rockies jump out early
skies this one it's a light sky right
now with the roof open cattell was out
there gives way to calhoun
[Applause]
oh strike three doug eddings rings him
up
first strikeout for robbie ray two on
diaz the d.h
that's belted hard but right at nick
ahmed
john's previous outing
was a very good one and he gets a
strikeout 96 early so maybe he's got a
little carlos estevez going right
this is in the air to left sam hilliard
sets his feet he's got it two outs
go in with the heater and uh that strike
three at 96. so you know what
that was the john gray we're all
accustomed to stick
swinging to miss on the curve ball
second strikeout for robbie who's now
sit down four in a row
doug eddings rings up hillyard on a
fastball that appeared to be well
outside but we'll take it
five in a row set down by robbie ray
doug evans has already heard some
barking out of that first base dugout
for some of his strike calls back in the
first inning i would imagine he heard a
few uh barks on that one
they found the blood clot strike three
and robbie strikes out the side he's got
four strikeouts among the six outs one
two three with the rockies brewers
philly's mets or diamondbacks as robbie
ray has now struck out
four consecutive rockies weren't sure if
this one was going to be played two and
two
[Applause]
robbie ray goes to the horned slider
strikes out blackman he's punched out
six and they leave this one two nothing
right there fastball at 91. seven
strikeouts for robbie ray here's
hillyard second and third nobody out
wing into this went to the slider
that's eight strikeouts for robbie ray
[Applause]
popped it up
that's drifting out to left center
david's under it diaz at third and he
will stay there
a little flare gonna have to hustle cole
calhoun makes a nice running grab
[Applause]
good start to the d-box fourth their
first two hits in the ball game and now
here's christian walker
walker sends that out to left field
hilliard backing up he's got it here
comes starling
an rbi for christian diamondbacks on the
board it's 2-1
one more good slider from johan lopez
strands two and keeps it a 2-1 ball game
and that's a heater 95 and that
dispatches of stephen vogt garrett
hamson a walk the strikeout trying to
drive home sam hilyard
and this ball on the ground toward the
hole it'll sneak through hilliard around
third he'll come home garrett hampson
drives in the rocky's third run
down the line and fair long throw for
escobar
and story safe hampson hustles into
third
and how about that job by nick ahmed to
get over there and cover the bag and
hampson makes the final out of the
inning at third base
one and two on arenado
did he go yes he did bill miller down at
first watch out
[Applause]
bill miller's giving him some leash here
[Applause]
there's a gesture
and
he's going to make it back to the dugout
sam hilliard will lead it off and this
ball is hammered right field and deep
right field at god make it 4-1
sam hilliard with his fourth of the year
great speed and great power
right there
riley smith
faces his first batter in the big
leagues and he strikes out trevor story
base is loaded and the leading hitter in
the national league strides up there
and this ball hammered high and deep
right field take a good look you won't
see it for long
grand
slam charlie blackman
this is well hit to center starling
martay gives it a ride again near the
home run porch this one off the wall
starling on the run it bounces back
toward
center martin's in a third with an rbi
triple
reaches out and knocks it into left
center field that'll get starling home
walker hustling into second you better
make it and he's in there
rbguy double for christian walker
[Applause]
punches one to first fuentes gets one
and that's it ahmed's home and it's
eight to four
that one is going to drop in front of
the hillyard
vote is home the bases are still loaded
walker sends one out to left and that
ball is off the wall he just missed it
cattell is home starling is home walker
just missed a walk off grand slam nick
ahmed with the bases loaded and two outs
and the tying run 90 feet away
strike three called on the outside
corner the rockies escape in the ninth
inning